[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition du
journal de la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le jeudi 10 septembre voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
les maires face à une violence sans
précédent l'année dernière 383 mer ont
été frappés ou insulter en france et des
fêtes qui se terminent parfois un drame
comme assis nous l'édile a été tué en
août 2019
le phénomène grandissant inquiète aussi
dans les yvelines le début d'année
scolaire perturbée par le cos vide 19
pour éviter la propagation du virus des
dispositifs d'ouverture de portes ont
été déployés dans les écoles de
guyancourt est la trouvaille a été mise
au point par un jeune habitant de la
ville
et puis la page dédiée à la législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines premier tour dimanche 20
septembre
onze candidats sont déclarés invités
thibault langlois suppléant de valérie
froberger en lice pour la france
insoumise et le parti communiste
à suivre également dans cette édition la
présentation de la saison à la
commanderie
le lancement officiel est donné ce
samedi
insultes menaces et parfois même
agression physique la violence envers
les élus locaux augmentent en france
rien qu'entre janvier et juillet 2020 de
cent trente trois édiles ont subi des
violences selon l'association des maires
de france est la tendance inquiète aussi
dans les yvelines comme l'a constaté
eléonore sinoquet le 30 août dernier
sami damerdji maire de mantes la ville
est menacée de mort par un tag devant
son hôtel de ville
début juillet son confrère de mantes la
jolie raphaël connu faisait face à la
même situation créant un sentiment
d'insécurité grandissant chez les élus
yvelinois élu maire de plaisir depuis
joséphine coleman ce berger ressent
cette augmentation de la violence
je compatis auprès de mes collègues par
rapport à tout ce qu'ils ont pu subir
moi même j'ai eu il ya quelques temps
aussi des agressions et aussi j'ai reçu
des menaces par écrit j'ai reçu un
caillou sur sur une jambe alors sa
paille qui gravissime et le geste en soi
n'est pas acceptable
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de poursuites
par rapport à ça il va falloir aussi que
la population comprenne que nous ne
devons pas et des pulls chili bowl on
doit pas être là des boucs émissaires de
tous et de tout ce stress bien sûr qui
est dans la société on est là au
contraire pour les accompagner du côté
de lévis saint nom la première édile and
green on le reconnaît elle n'a jamais eu
à subir cette violence mais souhaitent
tout de même plus de sanctions toute
mesure qui permettra de combattre ce
sentiment d'impunité et de rétablir
l'autorité du maire sera évidemment la
bienvenue dans la violence envers les
élus est un sujet évidemment extrêmement
grave et qu'il faut combattre
on a eu quelques quelques exemples cet
été un de deux mères qui avaient été
frappés insultes etc et pour lesquels il
n'y a eu que des 2 simple rappel à la
loi donc c'est évidemment absolument
inacceptable un souhait entendu par le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti
depuis le 7 septembre les insultes
envers les mères sont désormais
qualifiées d' outrage impliquant la mise
en oeuvre de travaux d'intérêt général à
ce phénomène envers les mères est il le
signe d'une banalisation plus générale
de la violence en france c'est ce que
gérald darmanin le ministre de
intérieure a qualifié d'ensauvagement de
la société écoutez ce qu en pense
arnaud péricard il est le maire de saint
germain en laye il avait signé en
juillet dernier une tribune à ce sujet
avec 17 autres élus dans le journal du
dimanche les propos collectées par
eléonore synopsis c'est le témoin en
tout cas d'un délitement de la relation
à l'autorité de la relation à l'ordre ce
sont des principes fondateurs d'ailleurs
sont dans l'adn de notre république
la sécurité est avant tout l'une des
constituantes de l'égalité entre entre
tous entre entre citoyens si on a une
présence policière qui est plus présente
si on a des moyens technologiques qui
nous permettent de sanctionner plus
rapidement bien évidemment qu'on va
lutter plus efficacement contre contre
tout contre tout cela alors je veux pas
rentrer dans la sémantique ensauvagement
incivilités peu importe ce sont des
faits des faits qui sont aujourd'hui
banalisé et il faut absolument qu'on ait
cette réponse qui soit ferme qu'elle
soit rapide et qu'elle soit efficace si
on veut enrayer dans le reste de
l'actualité le kovy 19 qui continuent de
perturber le début d'année scolaire près
d'une dizaine de classes a été fermée
dans les yvelines après que des cas de
pod positive de kobe de 19 été révélé
avec à chaque fois des mesures de
quarantaine prononcé pour les élèves et
pour les équipes encadrantes une classe
de cm2 à rambouillet à l'école de la
louvière une classe de cm1 à l'école
georges guynemer duchesnay rocancourt à
versailles c'est la maternelle entière
des dauphins qui a fermé ses portes en
fin de classe également du côté de la
cité royale qui sont concernés à l'école
élémentaire de la quintinie et une aot
wapler des mesures de fermeture prononcé
par l'équipe de les équipes de
l'éducation nationale et l'agencé
régionale de santé
à noter enfin que la crèche des essarts
le roi a aussi été close après un cas
avéré dans les écoles de guyancourt pour
éviter justement la propagation du
coronavirus les poignées de portes ont
été équipées d'un dispositif ingénieux
il était mise au point par un jeune
guyancourt toi avec le soutien de la
municipalité
marie pas neutre à eléonore sinoquet
on ouvre les portes des clubs le nouveau
quotidien de la directrice de maternelle
ne plus toucher les poignets elle s'est
habituée à utiliser son bras pour entrer
dans la classe depuis la rentrée
scolaire
toutes les portes sont équipés d'un
dispositif anti qu'ovide les enfants se
sont pris au jeu
son plus petit donc ils peuvent mettre
une grande partie du bras et avoir
beaucoup plus de prise que nous une
installation qui sécurise l'équipe
encadrante
c'est toujours rassurant toute façon
toutes les mesures qui sont prises pour
essayer d'éviter d'avoir des contacts
collectif et qui peut enrayer toute
épidémie
nous on met tout en place on est tout en
oeuvre c'est vraiment extrêmement
important dans les écoles
cela a été rendu possible grâce à un
jeune guyancourt toi léo morlot ça
chauffe et à mâcher pour danser une
pièce de la première ronde russe pendant
le confinement le jeune en reconversion
se passionne pour les impressions
numériques et propose ses services à la
ville il fallait aider
il y avait moyen d'aider et en plus
moyen d'apprendre
bah c'est tout bénef en fait j'ai vu un
message passé sur facebook où aller
chercher des gens qui avaient des
imprimantes et pour pouvoir faire ça et
bah bah oui j'ai foncé en moyenne une
petite vingtaine de poignet était
imprimé par jour très école et une
crèche sont déjà équipés à guyancourt
on va déployer sur les maisons cartier
sur tous les bâtiments qui sont censés
accueillir du public
l'idée c'est toujours évité les ondes de
contentement qu on continue à se protège
collectivement pour cela la mairie a
investi 6000 euros
ce dispositif pourra également servir
aux personnes à mobilité réduite
l'association a été est pleinement
toujours mobilisés dans cette crise
sanitaire du coc vide 19 la croix rouge
française organise ses journées
nationales c'est du 12 au 18 septembre
un événement prévu à l'origine au mois
de juin est finalement reportée en cette
rentrée
particularité cette année le rendez-vous
coïncide avec la journée mondiale des
premiers secours
ce samedi vous trouverez partout dans
les yvelines des bénévoles qui
proposeront des formations aux premiers
secours adaptés à ce temps de pandémie
c'est aussi le moment de la quête
nationale pour aider l'association
écouter la présidente de la délégation
territoriale des yvelines de la croix
rouge
nous avons impérativement besoin de la
générosité de toutes les personnes qui
nous font confiance
voilà et donc cette année pour tout dire
il y a trois moyens de pouvoir donner à
la croix rouge le premier vous allez
tout et partout dans les yvelines
des bénévoles qui vont venir avec les
trous comme d'habitude
le deuxième moyen et ça c'est nouveau
c'est que vous pouvez donner un don à
sms donc vous vous composerez le 92 200
avec dont 78 et vous pourrez donner 3
euros donc ça c'est très important et la
troisième nouveauté c'est que nous avons
une plateforme participative
il va nous permettre d'acheter 1000 kits
hygiène pour nos maraudeur de la
croix-rouge et samu social dans les
yvelines et nos bénévoles tous les soirs
de l'année font contact des gens
et ça ça serait vraiment un énorme
service
alors le site internet de la croix rouge
des yvelines qui s'affiche à nouveau
pour toutes les informations vous pouvez
également retrouver l'association sur
les réseaux sociaux
la maison de l'enfance des yvelines fête
ses 5 ans des bougies soufflées lundi
dernier l'établissement géré par le
conseil départemental est situé à
mantes-la-jolie il est réservé aux
mineurs qui sont confrontés à des
difficultés familiales 58 places
d'accueil pour des enfants qu'ils soient
nourrissons ou jeunes jusqu'à 17 ans ils
sont hébergés en moyenne pendant quatre
mois sur place les interviews collectées
par patrick jacques de dixmude et
bixente n'a rien senti steban et parfois
les parents sont en difficulté au point
de ne plus pouvoir prendre en charge
leurs enfants au domicile et donc ils
sont accueillis ici en urgence dans
cette maison le temps de comprendre ce
qui se passe dans la famille et parfois
devenir en suppléance des parents en
difficulté si on fait une moyenne
on arrive on en arrive à répondre aux
besoins de la population à hauteur de
200 enfants par an après le nombre est
important mais ce que ce qui est
extrêmement important dans les airs tel
exercice là c'est quand on nous appelle
en dix ans on a besoin de vous à 230
reprise on a dit ok c'est possible mais
ce sont en ce moment les premières
vendanges de l'année à d'avron les
fondateurs du domaine de la bouche du
roi ont présenté hier mercredi leurs
premiers millésimes à leurs partenaires
et notamment l conseil départemental qui
était sur place le reportage de michael
et demi d'euros à d'avron les stars du
jour sont ces bouteilles le millésime
2010 9 du domaine la bouche bureau a été
présenté ce mercredi 9 septembre dans
les vignes yvelines oise
ce vin blanc et rouge est issu de la
première plantation de 2010 est de 3 ha
soutenue par le conseil départemental
des yvelines le premier millésime et il
a une couleur particulière puisque c'est
celui qui qui arrive après trois ans de
travail puisqu'on la ville mais trois
ans à produire et donc surtout on est
très heureux d'avoir vu dans les cuves
se révéler vraiment le goût du terroir
et faire ses vins qui vont avoir le goût
du lieu où ils sont produits
c'était très excitant puisqu'on a suivi
c'est qu on a planté ses cépages en
fonction du terroir qui ici la
dégustation organisées ce jour-là a
permis de tester le niveau de ses
premières vendanges qui se sont déroulés
sur le site libinois du 22 septembre au
7 octobre 2019 le millésime 2010 9 s'est
très très bien passé on a une très belle
maturité et surtout on présente pour la
première fois la typicité la singularité
de ces cépages sur ce terroir qui n'a
pas vu devine depuis très longtemps et
qui permet d'avoir des vérins singulier
équilibré avec une grande pureté
aromatiques ces bouteilles de vin sont
vendus via le site de la bouche du roy
lé seront également distribués aux
partenaires locaux des alentours
en parallèle le domaine propose toujours
des visites de ses vignes au grand
public jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre après le patrimoine viticole
un peu de culture dans ce journal la
nouvelle saison à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines va démarrer
une soirée de lancement est prévue ce
samedi le programme avec astrid bergère
et justine brasil coup d'envoi de la
troisième saison culturelle samedi 12
septembre à la commanderie pour
l'occasion une soirée d'animation est
organisée ce lieu très convivial donc
l'objectif c'est que les petits et les
grands
retrouvent dans une ambiance conviviale
dans une ambiance festive et joyeuse
pour démarrer cette saison culturelle
qui se veut ambitieuse avec de nombreux
événements qui vont là jalonné tout au
long de la saison
spectacle de danse chariot pour réaliser
des expériences scientifiques
combi volkswagen dans lequel on pourra
écouter de la poésie les animations sont
mariés
l'objectif c'est de faire participer
parce que la volonté de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est une culture qui soit tournée vers
les habitants est à la fois la culture
va au devant des habitants et les
habitants doivent venir aussi au devant
en plus des animations des food truck
seront présents pour permettre aux
habitants de se restaurer dans la
convivialité
l'événement sera donc un avant goût des
temps forts de la saison sur le prochain
trimestre il y aura donc les journées du
patrimoine dont une partie se passera
ici il y aura un week-end science et
puis ira le fameux noël décalé que tout
le monde attend maintenant depuis
l'année dernière
la saison culturelle tournera autour de
plusieurs thèmes comme les arts visuels
la science ou encore la poésie la soirée
de lancement elle débutera à 17h et sera
gratuite
[Musique]
avant de parler de la législative
partielle un autre scrutin dont le
dénouement se jouait aujourd'hui aurore
bergé ne sera pas la présidente du
groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale est la députée de
la 10e circonscription des yvelines
s'incline au deuxième tour de l'élection
interne face à christophe castaner 145
voix contre 120 aurore bergé s'était
qualifiée hier pour le second tour et
avait reçu le soutien personnel de
françois de rugy en lice au premier tour
ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale de la 10e à la 11e
circonscription des yvelines où une
législative partielle est programmé
élection rendue nécessaire après la
démission de nadia qui est entré au
gouvernement premier tour le dimanche 20
septembre éventuel deuxième tour le
dimanche 27 septembre
onze candidats sont en lice pour ce
scrutin les noms peut-être qu'ils vont
s'afficher dans un instant pour cette
11e circonscription avec moi en plateau
en tout cas thibault langlois
bonsoir bonsoir mais ce canal et vous
êtes le candidat suppléant de valérie
froberger vous êtes vous pour la france
insoumise valérie offre aux bergers du
parti communiste français puisque les
deux formations ont choisi de s'unir
pour le scrutin dans la 11e
circonscription déjà pourquoi cette
candidature et pourquoi partir une autre
pour le pour l'élection pourquoi cette
candidature et bien je pense qu'on peut
faire le constat que la situation
économique du pays est assez est assez
désastreuse
on savait déjà que notre système
fonctionne et mal avec la crise
sanitaire
c'est devenu particulièrement évident
avec les suppressions d'emplois qui se
multiplient et nous pensons que la
réponse du président de la république
n'est pas la bonne on l'a vu sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire a été assez
erratique assez autoritaire aussi à
présent le plan d'investissement qui est
proposée qui est certes conséquent se
contentent de distribuer des aides
certes massive à des entreprises qui
continuait en même temps de licenciés de
polluer voir les 2 dont on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler juste après et
pourquoi parler partir pendant unis dans
cette élection avec le parti communiste
français sionisés le parti communiste
français nous avons nous avons à coeur
tous les deux de défendre l'humain
d'abord 2
de véritablement investir dans dans la
vie des gens dont social dans l'écologie
proposer une véritable alternative à la
présidence macron donc nous avions de
véritable convergence de vues et c'est
ce qui a amené cette candidature au tour
de valérie froberger qui est aide
soignante et nous pensons que elle
représente bien les gens qui travaillent
les gens qui ont été en première ligne
pendant cette crise et qui valérie qui
portera une voie écologique démocratique
populaire à l'assemblée nationale alors
il n'y aura pas pour autant une union
des gauches union totale dé gauche
puisque la concert régional et premier
adjoint de la mairie de trappes sandrine
gangs se présente également une
candidature sous la bannière de
génération avec un soutien d'europe
écologie les verts cette union plus
large n'était pas possible à ce que des
discussions ont eu lieu pour un éventuel
rassemblement lors des discussions
auront éventuellement quand évidemment
eu lieu cependant nous avons appris et
lacan déclaration de candidature de son
nom gambe alors que celle ci était
toujours était toujours en cours nous
avons appris par votre presse donc nous
en avons pris acte voilà pour le fond
pour la forme et pour le fond c'est vrai
qu'il y avait
certaines inconnues sur la candidature
de madame en vente par exemple le groupe
qu'elle rejoindrait à l'assemblée
nationale les positions qu'elle allait
défendre on ne savait pas trop s'il
allait les rejoindre un groupe qu'on
nouveau ps qui a voté non certain nombre
ont voté la confiance au gouvernement
successifs voir un groupe de maquereaux
nice de gauche si lente et que ça existe
et est ce que la porte est totalement
fermé ou un éventuel éventuelle
qualification au second tour pourrait
amener à rediscuter à nouveau dans ma
foi on verra en fonction des tailles
rapport de force mais je pense vraiment
que nous avons des chances d'aller au
second tour est de représenter
voilà le de représenter véritablement la
force de l'opposition populaire alors
pas besoin de vous aider celles que vous
avez envie de porter à l'assemblée
nationale vous parliez tout à l'heure ce
plan de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
qui a été annoncé par le gouvernement
35 milliards d'euros seront dédiés aux
entreprises et les tpe et pme ça ça a
été a annoncées vont avoir des impôts
réduit ça c'est pas suffisant il fallait
aller plus loin selon vous le problème
c'est que par exemple vous avez ddm
massifs ont été attribués à des
entreprises comme airbus comme air
france comme comme total si je crois des
entreprises qui pour autant ne sont pas
tenus de préserver l'emploi ou
d'investir massivement dans l'écologie
c'est vraiment des aides qui sont
distribués sans la préparation sans
véritable planification d'ailleurs cette
nomination de françois bayrou au poste
de commissaire est commissaire au plan
de commissaire au plan et
est assez en effet d'annonce mais je
sais des conventions qui eux aussi
l'économie française au tir aussi
l'économie française mais qui vont être
pris dans les mailles du réchauffement
climatique qui vont devoir s'adapter
alors ce travail d'adaptation n'est pas
fait du tout ce que nous proposons nous
c'est d'inciter justement il entreprit
qui reçoivent d'obliger les entreprises
qui reçoivent des aides à réussir en
saveurs de pour les énergies décarbonées
pour les mobilités douces et surtout de
maintenir l'emploi dont la majorité de
nos concitoyens qui sont scénaristes
travaillent ont besoin d'ailleurs il
faut aussi mettre l'accent sur l'aide
aux tpe pme aux petites entreprises qui
sont dans une situation extrêmement
difficile en ce moment un mot d'un autre
axe que vous aurez sans doute l'occasion
de développer au cours d'un débat c'est
de la gratuité du port du masque un la
gratuité des masques pour tout ça ça a
été tranchée par le gouvernement il y
aura pas de gratuité pour les français
vous souhaitez la gratuité c'est une
très mauvaise chose parce que sur ceux
sur ce plan de ce plan de relance de 100
milliards on aurait quand même pu mettre
quelque argent de côté pour soulager un
peu les familles modestes et retraités
ces familles sur lesquels ce budget
masse que peu pesé de manière assez
conséquent ça peut monter à 100 euros
plus on aura l'occasion de développer un
peu plus les thématiques 1 au cours d'un
débat auquel participeront les candidats
de cette 11e circonscription dans cette
11e circonscription des yvelines merci
thibault langlois d'être venu en plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes le candidat
suppléant de valérie froberger pour
cette candidature commune je le rappelle
entre la france insoumise et le parti
communiste français
juste avant de rendre l'antenne un autre
candidat jérémy bizet pour france
écologie sera en campagne sur le terrain
samedi matin à lui et son équipe seront
présents sur le marché de saint cyr
l'école c'est à partir de 10h30
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]